[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen die us open und mehr
gleich im sport von norbert lehmann
also von mir schauen wir auf die themen
des tages
zustimmung in nürnberg markus söder wird
auf dem parteitag als csu chef
wiedergewählt und stellt sich hinter
kanzlerkandidat laschet
verschärfte corona regeln in mehreren
bundesländern
wer ungeimpft in quarantäne muss bekommt
bald keinen lohn mehr
und im würgegriff der taliban die neuen
machthaber in afghanistan gehen immer
brutaler gegen kritiker vor und
kontrollieren das öffentliche leben
die csu hat heute ihren parteitag
begonnen gut zwei wochen sind es noch
bis zur bundestagswahl und die
umfragewerte der union sind sehr
schlecht dementsprechend groß scheint
die nervosität bei cdu/csu wir schauen
gleich auf das aktuelle zdf
politbarometer
zuerst einmal aber der blick zum treffen
der christsozialen in nürnberg wo
parteichef markus söder wiedergewählt
wurde alexander pohl auf markus söder in
velen genau 600 jahr schwimmen das ist
ein wahlergebnis von 87,6 prozent
man sieht es markus söder an zwölf tage
vor der bundestagswahl hatte er sich
wohl mehr erwartet bei der suche nach
den gründen kommt man schnell auf seine
corona politik aber auch das verhalten
gegenüber armin laschet er selbst hatte
immer wieder zweifel an seiner
unterstützung für den kanzlerkandidaten
der union gesät heute wollte er diesen
zweifel ausräumen
für alle journalisten zum mitschreiben
wir wollen armin laschet als kanzler
haben staat olaf scholz oder annalena
baerbock liebe freunde
doch erst gestern hatte seinen
generalsekretär markus blume dem spiegel
ein interview gegeben und betont
natürlich stünden wir mit markus söder
besser da
ein klarer affront heute gibt blume ein
wenig nach im ton nicht im inhalt
und wenn man dann seine partei zuerst
denkt liebe freunde dann kann man auch
das sagen was man denkt manchmal sagt
man es vielleicht etwas zu deutlich
unter den knapp 900 delegierten haben
sich jetzt viele mit armin laschet
arrangiert und erwarten dass auch von
der parteispitze ich gebe die chance und
oder
in gottes namen wird schon gut gehen die
umfragen sind momentan gut für uns und
wir müssen in den nächsten 14 tagen um
einen riesigen endspurt hinlegen und
alles was vorher war einfach vergessen
armin laschet wird morgen hier seinen
großen auftritt haben er wird noch
einiges an überzeugungsarbeit leisten
müssen
und vor ort auf dem parteitag ist für
uns ralf schumacher gestern störfeuer
heute ein bild der geschlossenheit wie
glaubwürdig ist das
es ist zumindest der versuch nicht noch
mehr porzellan zu zerschlagen im
unions-internen machtgerangel und keine
weiteren stammwähler zu vergraulen die
csu ist hochnervös weil die schwachen
umfragewerte für armin laschet auch im
süden durchschlagen und den nimbus als
bayerische volkspartei gefährden und
damit natürlich auch den machtanspruch
in berlin markus söder versucht die
trendumkehr mit klarem lagerwahlkampf
stabilität und freiheit statt
linksrutsch so das motto mit teils
drastischen warnungen vor neuen schulden
steuererhöhungen und enteignung sollte
es zu einer regierungsbildung ohne union
kommen spanne dann morgen wenn laschet
kommt und wie die csu ihn hier empfängt
kritik am kanzler kandidaten an seinem
wahlkampf kaum vorstellbar auf offener
bühne aber sie wird bleiben und bei
vielen auch die überzeugung mit söder
wäre es besser gelaufen die große
abrechnung kommt nach der wahl vielen
dank für diese einschätzung ralf
schumacher
legen wir jetzt auf das neue zdf
politbarometer mit matthias fornoff
guten abend mit ersten halo genannt wie
stehen die parteien da in der gunst der
wählerinnen und wähler na ja es hat ja
viele veränderungen gegeben in den
letzten wochen jetzt sehen wir dass die
zahlen sich eher verfestigen wenn am
nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
käme die union auf 22 prozent die spd 25
afd fdp 11 alle unverändert zur letzten
woche linke 6 minus 1 grüne 17 und freie
wähler 3 prozent das würde sehr knapp
reichen für eine große koalition dreier
koalitionen rücken in den fokus sind
aber nicht besonders beliebt eine rote
ampel aus spd grünen und fdp ende
immerhin noch jeder dritte gut eine
unionsgeführte ampel und rot grün rot
werden mehrheitlich für schlecht
befunden
den hätten die wählerinnen und wähler am
liebsten als bundeskanzler
beziehungsweise bundeskanzlerin da ist
auf jeden fall bewegung gegeben wir
schauen uns mal die zahlen an armin
laschet und annalena baerbock machen im
vergleich zur vorwoche etwas boden gut
der abstand zum führenden olaf scholz
bleibt aber sehr groß fast jeder zweite
wünscht sich den spd kandidaten als
kanzler und mit wem würde die spd
regieren wenn sie denn die wahl hätte
dann sollte sie mit grünen und fdp
regieren sagt eine mehrheit von 55
prozent 29 prozent während für ein
bündnis mit grünen und linke dass sich
die spd auch für die rote ampel
entscheiden würde glaubt eine mehrheit
von 51 prozent
ein linksbündnis erwarten die befragten
also nicht was die erfolgsaussichten
einer rote-socken-kampagne er schmälert
wichtig bei alldem 41 wissen noch nicht
ob und wen sie wählen wollen es bleibt
spannend dankeschön und
das gesamte zdf politbarometer können
sie ab 22 uhr im heute journal sehen und
schon jetzt und jederzeit online in
unserer zdf heute apps finden sie alle
zahlungen grafiken zum durchklicken
im wahlkampf setzen cdu csu jetzt
verstärkt auf die themen innere und
äußere sicherheit
kanzlerkandidat und cdu-chef laschet
stellte dazu heute ein programm vor es
reicht von bewaffneten drohnen für die
bundeswehr bis zu mehr befugnissen für
die polizei karl hitler leiter berichtet
offiziell ging es heute im konrad
adenauer haus um das thema sicherheit im
mittelpunkt dabei aber seinen wahlkampf
die botschaft ist eindeutig deutschland
sei ein sicheres land aber es gebe noch
herausforderungen denen er als kanzler
begegnen wolle deshalb ist frage innere
sicherheit wehrhafter staat eine der
fragen über die bei dieser
bundestagswahl auch entschieden wird und
auch hier eine richtungsentscheidung und
ich möchte als bundeskanzler risiken
minimieren und sicherheit gewährleisten
gemeinsam mit verteidigungsministerin
kramp karrenbauer und experten stellte
laschet eine sicherheits agenda die cdu
für deutschland vor darunter die
wesentlichen punkte eine erhöhung der
verteidigungsausgaben auf zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts
bewaffnete drohnen für die bundeswehr
und die gründung eines nationalen
sicherheitsrates in dem alle
entscheidenden behörden vertreten sind
forderungen die die opposition vehement
zurückweist na ja das sind ja in großen
teilen vorschläge die von der union
immer wieder kommen also ängste zu
schüren und antworten zu geben die wir
für grundsätzlich falsch halten und die
spd-vorsitzende geht auf inhalte gar
nicht erst ein sieht den heutigen
auftritt laschet nur als zeichen von
nervosität
ich glaube dass diese papiere die jetzt
täglich
erscheinen ausdruck schira panik sind
angesichts auch der zustimmungswerte die
sehr sehr schwierig sehr problematisch
sind für die cdu ich empfehle ruhe die
fordert auch armin laschet und betont
noch das rennen ums kanzleramt sei offen
sein termin heute der versuch das thema
sicherheit im wahlkampf für die union zu
besetzen
die durchsuchungen im finanz- und
justizministerium gestern haben wohl ein
parlamentarisches nachspiel
mehrere oppositionsparteien wollen eine
sondersitzung des finanzausschusses
beantragen finanzminister scholz trage
die verantwortung für mögliche
missstände bei der bekämpfung von
geldwäsche in deutschland so die
begründung der ob leute von grünen
linken und fdp gegenüber der deutschen
presse agentur
die sitzung soll noch vor der
bundestagswahl stattfinden
zur corona pandemie und als erstes zwei
wichtigen meldungen die auswirkungen auf
die impfquote haben könnten denn die
stiko empfiehlt jetzt auch schwangeren
und stillenden sich zu impfen für sie
sei der impfstoff sicher und wirksam und
das mainzer unternehmen bei montech
kündigte einen impfstoff für kinder ab
fünf jahren an in den kommenden wochen
werde die zulassung beantragt der
impfstoff sei derselbe wie für
erwachsene nur niedriger dosiert die
impfung soll vor schweren verläufen
schützen auf den intensivstationen
nehmen die fälle seit einigen wochen
aber wieder zu die meisten kurven 19
patientinnen dort sind derzeit nur als
60 und eines haben fast alle gemeinsam
mehr als 90 prozent von ihnen sind nicht
geimpft sagt der
bundesgesundheitsminister wer die
spritze nicht will trägt das
gesundheitliche risiko in manchen
bundesländern kommt jetzt ein
finanzielles dazu keine lohnfortzahlung
mehr im quarantäne fall und dort wo zwei
gilt drohen auch freizeit
einschränkungen es wenn glas mit den
details
impfen in der disco ohne
terminvereinbarung möglichst
niedrigschwellig soll dieses angebot in
stuttgart sein einige kommen jetzt auch
weil ungeimpfte unter anderem in baden
württemberg in zukunft mit mehr
einschränkungen rechnen müssen ich
musste drei viermal zu verschieben weil
ich eben keine zeit hatte und jetzt
kommen diese strenge regelungen dachte
ich mir bezahlt in der regel keine
erstattung der verdienstausfälle mehr
für den der wegen corona in quarantäne
muss diese regelung führt baden
württemberg ab kommender woche ein als
erstes bundesland
wir haben ausgerechnet dass ihre 15
september das war mit sicherheit
lieferwagen grünen bürger ein angebot
von uns gekommen hat sich also hätte
impfen lassen können man setze damit das
bundes infektionsschutzgesetz um das bei
einem ausreichenden impfangebot diese
zahlung nicht mehr vorsieht andere
länder wollen bald nachziehen zb nrw und
rheinland pfalz dort wo ich
eigenverantwortlichen das ist ja auch
unser wunsch dass die menschen eigen
verantwortung übernehmen in der korona
pandemie sie dort entscheiden dass sie
sich nicht impfen lassen kann dieser
mensch auch nicht davon ausgehen dass
staatliche oder leistungen der
arbeitgeber am ende letztlich übernommen
werden darüber hinaus drohen in baden
württemberg nicht geimpften bald weitere
einschränkungen bei einer hohen zahl von
corona patienten in krankenhäusern oder
auf intensivstationen soll künftig statt
3g eine zweijährige gelten nicht
geimpfte dürften dann zum beispiel nicht
mehr ins restaurant oder ins kino die
politik erhöht also den druck auf
ungeimpfte das auch zu kritik führte
wenn mein verhalten tatsächlich ändern
möchte dann geht es mit anreizen aber
nicht mit verboten und was wir jetzt
hören das wird letztendlich in einer
weiteren spaltung eine alle mal schön
gestalteten gesellschaft in den
krankenhäusern unterdessen steigt
bundesweit die zahl der kooi quelle und
die zahl der intensivpatienten hat sich
in den letzten zwei wochen fast
verdoppelt
und damit zu den aktuellen corona zahlen
in deutschland
die sieben tage ins ident ist wieder
etwas gestiegen auf jetzt 83,8 innerhalb
eines tages kam 520 corona patientinnen
neu ins krankenhaus die hospitalisierung
rate stieg auf 1,95 fälle pro 100.000
einwohner die zahl der
krankenhauseinweisungen ist jetzt also
entscheidend bei der frage welche corona
maßnahmen es gibt dem hat heute auch der
bundesrat in einer sondersitzung
zugestimmt
thomas condor hat sich die
hospitalisierung rate genauer angeschaut
die bekannte sieben tage incidents sie
half frühzeitig zu warnen stieg die
inzidenz also die zahl der
neuinfektionen dann stieg die gefahr
dass viele patienten die krankenhäuser
überlasten mittlerweile sind aber viele
ältere und gefährdete geimpft also
besser geschützt steigt nun die
incidents dann müssen krankenhäuser
nicht unbedingt mit viel mehr patienten
rechnen der wert verliert an
aussagekraft
deshalb soll die entscheidende
richtschnur nun eine andere sein die
hospitalisierung rate sie gibt an wie
viele corona patienten ins krankenhaus
mussten und zwar je 100.000 einwohner
binnen sieben tagen seit juli müssen die
krankenhäuser dazu ein weisungen an die
gesundheitsämter melden die geben die
zahlen ans lka problem das institut
veröffentlicht derzeit eine oft
unvollständige rate die vollständige
liegt häufig erst nach zehn tagen
verzögerung vor
weiteres problem die bundesweite rate
sagt wenig über die einzelnen länder aus
sie sagt nicht ob die krankenhäuser dort
ans limit kommen
deshalb können die länder festlegen bei
welcher hospitalisierung welche
warnstufe gilt beispiel niedersachsen
bei mehr als 6 9 und 12
zusätzlich relevant können seien die
belegung speziell der intensivbetten und
die bekannte sieben tage incidents je
nach warnstufe gelten dann bestimmte am
thie corona regeln
in dänemark gibt es seit heute keine
corona beschränkungen mehr möglich macht
diesen schritt die hohe impfquoten
73 prozent der bevölkerung sind
vollständig geimpft bei den über 50
jährigen sind es sogar mehr als 90
prozent damit ist ab sofort der
uneingeschränkte besuch der gastronomie
und von großveranstaltungen möglich ohne
den nachweis dass man geimpft genesen
oder getestet ist
in kabul ist offenbar am späten
nachmittag eine zweite maschine mit mehr
als 150 afghaninnen und afghanen und
ausländer in richtung katar gestartet
darunter sollen auch deutsche seien nach
angaben der vereinten nationen wurden
bei den jüngsten protesten mindestens
vier demonstrierende getötet wir wollen
jetzt genauer schauen wie es außerhalb
der hauptstadt kabul aussieht dafür
gehen wir in den norden afghanistans
nach masar i scharif wo die bundeswehr
stationiert war in masar i scharif ist
für uns katrin eigendorf kathrin wie hat
die machtübernahme der taliban das leben
in der stadt verändert
die komplette stadt masar i scharif und
auch die umgebung der ganze norden
afghanistans ist in konter unter
kontrolle der taliban wenn man hier
durch die stadt läuft überall ob in
parks auf den straßen ob vor den
moscheen überall sind gruppen von schwer
bewaffneten kämpfern die alles
kontrollieren auch wir als journalisten
als ausländische journalisten können uns
hier nicht frei bewegen wir brauchten
eine genehmigung der taliban wir mussten
die heute noch mal bestätigen lassen man
hat gesagt wir dürfen hier in der stadt
drehen aber nicht mit den menschen reden
ganz ausdrücklich war das nicht erlaubt
aber man musste gar nicht mit den
menschen reden wenn man einfach hier in
der öffentlichkeit herum läuft dann ist
die angst die einschüchterung spürbar
man sieht auch kaum noch frauen die
nicht in burka oder vollverschleiert
durch die stadt gehen es gibt auch keine
frauen die alleine hier in der stadt zu
sehen sind das ist die situation und wie
unberechenbar die auch ist haben wir
selber erfahren weil wir hatten zwar die
genehmigung einer taliban gruppe sind
aber dann auf eine an gestoßen die uns
gesagt hat wir dürfen nicht mehr drehen
also es gibt auch grabenkämpfe unter den
taliban die radikalen versuchen hier
immer mehr den ton anzugeben und das
könnte sich sicherlich auch noch ganz
ganz negativ auf die sicherheitslage
hier auswirken ihren dank hat den
eigendorf aus afghanistan
zurück nach deutschland
in hamburg ist heute der körber preis
für die europäische wissenschaft
verliehen worden er ist mit einer
million euro dotiert und eine der
wichtigsten auszeichnungen für
forschende weltweit bekommen hat ihn die
chemikerin claire gray aus cambridge die
briten arbeitet seit jahrzehnten an der
entwicklung von leistungsfähigen akkus
wie sie jetzt etwa in handys und e autos
eingesetzt werden der körper preis
würdigt grace forschung auch als
wichtigen beitrag für den klimaschutz
denn die energiewende braucht effiziente
speicher für grünen strom
fußball profi jerome boateng ist vom
amtsgericht münchen wegen vorsätzlicher
körperverletzung zu einer geldstrafe von
60 tagessätzen zu je 30.000 euro also
1,8 millionen euro verurteilt worden vor
drei jahren soll er seine damalige
lebensgefährtin geschlagen und beleidigt
haben boateng bestreitet die vorwürfe
die staatsanwaltschaft erwägt berufung
einzulegen
und wir kommen zu den us open noch
weiter stehen jetzt zwei spannende
begegnungen morgen abend das erste
teenager finale bei den frauen seit 22
jahren leila fehlern des 19 gegen emma
raducanu 18 und bereits heute nacht das
super halbfinale bei den männern wie
schon bei olympia in tokio trifft
alexander zverev auf novak djokovic
16 siege in serie alexander zverev
spielt nach dem olympiasieg auch in new
york weltklasse tennis nun gehts wie vor
exakt sechs wochen beim halbfinal
triumph in tokio wieder gegen novak
djokovic
und wieder ist der weltranglisten-erste
leicht favorisiert und bereit für das
erneute duell
ich kann und werde hier mit dem kopf und
ist topform auf dem platz stehen um
meine beste leistung abzurufen
bei olympia in tokio ist 12 das gelungen
und auch in new york kann er geschichte
schreiben
100 jahre berliner leichtathletik
meeting beim ist darf am sonntag wird
auch speerwerfer johannes vetter seinen
großen auftritt haben nach der olympia
pleite in tokio hat er sich für berlin
einiges vorgenommen es ist so dass
deutsche medien schlechthin es ist ein
meeting was international hoch geachtet
wird ich weiß mich nochmal ordentlich
amorim dass das am sonntag noch mal
klappt das primäre ziel ist auf alle
fälle zu gewinnen
morgen abend das fußball bundesliga
topspiel in leipzig rb empfängt bayern
münchen mit ex trainer julian nagelsmann
der die sachsen ja letzte saison
immerhin zur vizemeisterschaft geführt
hatte
einen freundlichen zuschauer empfangen
wird es wohl nicht geben vor allem nicht
für julia nagelsmann der beim
bekanntwerden des wechsels im april
betonte ich werde es nicht wie gesagt
ein t6 mieten oder was auch immer um
nach münchen zu fahren und im schlepptau
noch den anderen guten spieler von
leipzig dabei zu haben jetzt vielleicht
sogar den besten den ehemaligen kapitän
der auch noch insider wissen mitbringt
ich war ja noch vier wochen dabei in der
vorbereitung und auch in den ersten
spielen und deshalb habe ich natürlich
paar infos insiderinfos und habe mir mit
denen wir die analysten mit den
co-trainern bisschen ausgetauscht es
spricht also mal wieder vieles für die
bayern aber manchmal kommt es im fußball
ja dann doch ganz anders
ja und das topspiel leipzig gegen
münchen morgen abend ausführlich bei uns
im aktuellen sportstudio um 23 30
mein wetter ist es morgen noch unruhig
mit gewittern mehr dazu gleich von
westen telli um 22 uhr sehen sie hier
das heute journal mit christian sievers
machen das gut auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter heute gab sehr
kräftige schauer und gewitter im westen
deutschlands teils im unwetter bereich
mit starkregen das liegt an dieser front
die quasi über deutschland jetzt liegt
und sich weiterbewegt nach osten und
morgen gibt es dann schauer und gewitter
mit kräftigen regengüssen von der ostsee
bis an die alpen das hoch hier dehnt
sich aus und beruhigt die gesamte
wetterlage in der nacht also im norden
schauer teils mit blitz und donner das
lässt nach im südosten gibt es neu
gewitter dazwischen da ist es
größtenteils trocken mit vielen wolken
bei temperaturen von 12 grad an den
alpen häufig aber 14 15 16 grad und das
sind ja die tiefs werte also eine sehr
milde nacht morgen dann im osten schauer
und gewitter und nach südosten hin von
westen her lockert es auf und die sonne
zeigt sich und auch ganz im norden da
gibt es regen mit temperaturen bis 24
grad zum beispiel im osten deutschlands
und 19 grad an den alpen ja und die
nächsten tage werden ruhiger am sonntag
im norden schauer ansonsten aber
auflockerungen 19 bis 24 grad und ab
montag trocken und es wird wieder wärmer
ein schöner abend